I'm here to present the Irving Thalberg  award is a former winner and the  gentleman who runs 20th Century Fox the  company that produces oil we are happy  to introduce to you mr. buddy Adler's  ladies and gentlemen Wahlberg award is  given only when the Academy Board of  Governors decides there is a deserving  recipient it is given to the individual  who has been responsible for the most  consistent high quality of motion  picture production for the current  Awards year and the four preceding years  it gives me great pleasure to announce  that the board has voted the Thalberg  award to mr. Jack L Warner  Irving Thalberg whose memory this award  honors was a warm personal friend of  mine throughout his entire career I am  most grateful to the Academy Board of  Governors for this honor it is one that  I will always remember and cherish I  thank you very much  you